professor i didn't think i'd be talking
to you again so soon after we saw your
backyard astronomy but we've got
breaking news in space you've been
imaging it what's going on up there
yeah it's not often that we get things
happening you know as stop press as we
have for this particular event but
there's been a supernova has gone off in
messier 61 so one of our messier objects
is putting on a shower at the moment i
know there are different types of
supernova what's this particular one so
this is a type 2 supernova which means
that when you split the light of it up
into a spectrum you find there are
absorption lines of hydrogen in the
spectrum so what this is telling you is
that whatever is exploding you're seeing
through a lot of hydrogen so the
hydrogen is kind of obscuring a bit of
the explosion and absorbing some of the
light
and that tells you that what you're
looking at is a massive star
which still has all its sort of outer
layers of hydrogen on it so there's an
explosion going on in the core of this
star that we're seeing through the outer
layers of hydrogen of the star itself so
it still had lots of fuel in the tank
sort of
it has fuel and some of it will still be
actually physically bound to the star
some of it it will have blown out into
space in the late stages of its lifetime
but yes most stars end up with a lot of
their hydrogen left over before they
blow up okay so can you talk me through
what a type 2 supernova actually is what
happened to this ill-fated star sitting
there in m61 so this is a star right at
the end of its life it's a lot more
massive than the sun it's at least eight
times the mass of the sun and it's gone
through all the nuclear fuel burning
stages turning hydrogen into helium into
carbon into all the heavier elements
it's run out of fuel
and the the nuclear fusion is really
what holds the star up you know the pull
of gravity is trying to pull it inwards
on itself
and the the nuclear reactions in the
center are sort of generating the energy
necessary to hold it up against gravity
when you run out of those reactions the
whole thing just collapses down
and ends up uh
imploding essentially the whole star
collapses down uh on to the the center
of where the star used to be you end up
forming a neutron star right at the
center
as everything gets very compressed the
star then sort of bounces off that
neutron star flings its outer layers out
turns out that's not quite the whole
story that's not enough to make the star
explode completely but the other thing
that happens is the neutron star in the
center is initially incredibly hot and
starts cooling down and part of the way
it cools down is by producing pairs of
neutrinos which then also fly out
through the star some of those interact
with the gas that's just been flung out
and end up creating the enormous
explosion that we see the location that
this has happened within the galaxies of
interest too isn't it seems to be in one
of the the arms of the galaxy is that
normal uh yeah i mean so it's a very
massive star massive stars have very
short lifetimes at least by stellar
standards we're talking about you know
hundreds of thousands to millions of
years which really means that they don't
move very far from where they were born
before they blow up
and most stars form in spiral arms so
because it hasn't had time to move out
of its sort of birth place
you actually see it blowing up within
the spiral arm where it was born so most
stars are born in spiral arms because
that's where all the gas and the energy
and all the all the stuff's kicking off
but they don't stay there it's not like
as the arms swirl around the galaxy the
stars go with them
no you should think of spiral arms as
like waves which are traveling around
the galaxy and they travel around the
galaxy at their speed and the stars
travel around the galaxy at their speed
and they're not the same in most parts
of the galaxy in fact for most of the
galaxy the stars and the gas that make
up the galaxy travel faster than the
spiral arms and so the way that stars
form is that a gas cloud will travel
traveling faster than the spiral arm
will sort of catch up with it and
overtake it but as it passes through the
spiral arm it gets compressed by the
density wave of the spiral arm and that
compression is what triggers the star
formation and then the the after the
stars are formed the star as massive as
this supernova hadn't had time to travel
very far it sort of started traveling
towards the front edge of the spiral arm
but it won't have got very far and so
you'll still see it in the spiral arm
when it blows up okay so it's almost
like all the gas
is being lit up by the arms as the arms
move around and stars form when they
light up and then
but the stars will move at the speed
that the gas was moving at not the speed
that the waves were moving at yeah so
the stars will continue if it was a
slightly less massive star that wasn't
destined to explode shortly after
forming it would continue and continue
moving away from the front edge of the
spiral arm as it travels faster than it
okay so the sun for example moves in and
out of spiral arms as it merrily goes
around the milky way which it's done a
few times already yeah the sun has you
know it takes about what a couple
hundred million years to travel around
the milky way and it's been around for
billions of years so it's gone round the
milky way tens of times since it was
born but this poor one in m61 it didn't
get far it hardly got off the ground no
it really wasn't as you know it's as
soon as it was born basically it blew up
at least in sort of stellar terms and so
actually it really didn't have very much
time to travel anywhere is the sun
currently in or out of a spiral arm i
think we're in between at the moment
it's not not in a particularly exciting
part of the milky way at the moment will
we be able to go back into the archive
of pictures of m61 and find the star
that blew like say that was the one
that's where it was that was the one
that was just about to go and learn
anything from that i don't know in this
particular case but it is something that
people are doing more and more often now
um with hubble space telescope image
quality you can actually see the very
bright stars that go supernovae as
individual stars before they blew up so
if there happens to be a picture of the
right part of m61 then it will be
possible to go back and in fact this is
one of the ways we learn about the
supernova process is by looking at these
progenitors these stars which are going
to blow
and learning what kind of star it is
that that is just just before it blows
up how it looks just before it explodes
will we be able to go back afterwards
when all the light dies down and find
the remnant see what's left behind
probably not in this case because it's
almost certainly too faint i mean it for
supernova 1987a in the large magic
atlantic cloud so very much closer there
with really good imaging from the hubble
space telescope we've been able to start
studying the remnant that formed behind
the explosion
but this is just so much further away i
very much doubt we'll be able to see
anything once the supernova itself has
faded away now because this has happened
during the pandemic lockdown i was all
excited because this was you know i was
going to call this the corona supernova
but you've set me straight a bit and
apparently these are not particularly
rare events these things are banging all
the time
they really are and because so this one
was discovered with a telescope called
the zwicky transient facility which is
actually out scanning the skies the
entire time it covers the entire
northern sky every few nights so it's
collecting huge amounts of data and will
find pretty much all the supernovae that
go off sort of within its range
and so that actually when it used to be
the case we'd find you know maybe a
dozen or so supernovae a year um but now
with all these automated searches out
there we're finding literally thousands
of supernovae and we've actually had to
change the way we name supernova a bit
to make this fit in that for example
supernova 1987a was called that because
it was found in 1987 it was the first
one in 1987. and we used to just work
our way through the alphabet and then it
turned out that actually you run out of
letters to the alphabet so then we went
into using two letters so once you've
used all the single letters then you'd
have a a a b a c and so on but it turns
out now we're finding so many supernovae
that even two letters aren't enough so
now we have to go through three sets of
the alphabet and so this for example was
supernova 2020 jfo
and i'm sure uh the next few supernovae
have already been found since then so
actually we sort of it's the meters
clocking up very quickly on the names of
supernovae now is it possible has it
ever happened that someone is looking at
a galaxy and the supernova goes off like
you see the moment it blinks into
existence
you'd have to be very lucky but actually
there are an awful lot of astronomers
out there staring at the skies so sooner
or later you'd think it probably will
happen yeah
that'd be awesome you should be out
there doing that just watch
m61 is a good candidate you're telling
me that's a bit of a hotbed for
supernovas yeah it is because although
so typically you expect in a galaxy you
know like the milky way or m61 you
expect maybe one supernova every 50
years but actually this one has had you
know it had one so it's had one this
year there was another one in 2014 there
were at least another couple since 2000
so this one is a real real supernova
factory at the moment no one i think
really understands why why one galaxy
would suddenly produce a whole bunch of
supernovae i think it really just given
the very short timescale involved it has
to be just down to chance
um but yeah if you uh well it depends
which way you look at it right maybe you
say well m61 has had its fair share now
so you want to go and look somewhere
else but or maybe you want to say well
you know m61 is on a roll so maybe we
should just keep looking there if a
supernova went off in
a spiral arm and you were in the same
spiral arm
that would be pretty that would be a
good sight wouldn't it
it would be pretty impressive so you
remember a little while ago there was a
lot of excitement about maybe
beetlejuice was going to go um and there
you'd have had a supernova that you'd
been able to see during daytime from the
earth um which is a you know relatively
nearby star to us so yeah indeed if you
were in the right spiral alarm in m61
you'd be getting a bit of a show at the
moment yeah but you'd be safe as long as
that wasn't your star
you want to be a reasonable distance
away because there are gamma rays and
nasty things but but as soon as you get
you know unless it really is a nearby
neighbor you're probably fine
are you going to keep imaging this and
watch it brighten up and fade away or
have you you got a bit bored with this
one now and you're moving on no i'm
going to try so this one was caught
really early i think it's still
brightening up so it'll be interesting
to map out its light curve to see how
its light changes over the coming weeks
although i think i'm going to be
slightly at the mercy of the weather in
that the forecast looks cloudy for at
least the next week
you were pretty lucky to get this one
though you were showing me you had to
like thread the needle between the trees
and the house and that that's where it
is at the sky and things yeah there's a
tiny little patch of sky i could aim at
so it was m61 is kind of in the south
from here um and so the south is the
direction of my house from the back
garden which means that actually unless
it's quite high in the south you end up
looking at my house rather than the
object but it turns out there's a tiny
little patch in my garden where you can
just set up the telescope and see it
sort of next to the chimney pot
and i got lucky and actually really
lucky in the clouds cleared at just the
right moment for me actually to be able
to capture an image of it
you'll be able to get like an
occultation with the chimney part
i did well i have actually had things
disappear and thought i wonder where
that's gone and and it's because the
telescope's tracked in such a way that
the house has got in the way
oh you think you found this amazing
supernova it's your office window or
something
yeah no yeah well you've got to be
careful when you start pointing your
telescope into bedroom windows though
our spiral structure is that when you
calculate the procession speed of all
these orbits you find that they're all
the same that's how spiral structure
gets generated it's in the case where
you can have all those ellipses
processing at the same speed and that
procession so if you can think about it
you can think about the stars going
around and then the ellipse itself is
rotating i've sold the squeak by the way
you know what i solved the squeak
oh it's good well done wd-40 no i just
cranked the seat of the chair back so i
can't lean back